alexandria ocasio-cortez thinks you're a
sucker if you worked hard and paid off
your student debt the radical
congresswoman responding to a question
on how biden's plan would benefit those
who have already paid off their loans
quote i've said it before and i'll say
it again not every program has to be for
everybody people with apartments pay for
first-time homeowners benefits young
people pay for medicare for seniors
people who take public transit pay for
car infrastructure
all right makes sense to me how about
you greg
i pay for everything
i get nothing
nothing no i love how she explains it
they're not meant for you right but then
you have to ask okay then what
is this debt forgiveness who is it meant
for and when you look at the data it's
upper white middle-class liberal women
this ain't welfare right these are these
are well-to-do people it's a bribe for
democrats on the backs of plumbers
truckers and everyone else who actually
does a real job unlike me
aoc is the symbol of the entitled sponge
she complains about student loans but
she owns a tesla
and worse she owns a french bulldog
thanks to cat tampa i know everything
about french bulldogs and one thing i
know
they are so expensive
they're more expensive than any college
tuition that you got to take care of
them they're adorable dogs but she owns
a tesla and she owns a french bulldog
and she's out she wants you or your dad
the electrician to forgive her student
loan that's bs turn in the tesla
sell the dog i'll buy it half price
all right dana i'll go down the road
here
today the numbers the employment numbers
were they increased there are 11.5
million jobs available so this whole
argument that we have to cancel their
student debt is based on what other than
buying votes because there's so many
jobs they also say it's because of the
pandemic unless it's at the border then
it's not the pandemic so you see their
logic there um
the thing is about her is she they give
90 of the benefit to the top 60 of
incomes right and so you find who are
the constituencies now who who are they
actually trying to help and the other
thing when you mention she has a tesla
you also get a tax credit for that
because now you have a green vehicle
which is also for the wealthy this is
also murdering um
baffled by aoc and others who are just
demanding that joe biden take executive
action because they can't pass any laws
they are not persuasive enough to pass
any laws so they have to have
they try to have a king do it well you
know what's interesting joey is that uh
his name is rokahana has plans to
introduce legislation congressman to
cancel student loans emphasizing that
even though biden has the power to do it
he wants to legislate it well he's a
pretty he's actually a pretty moderate
member
respectively for the squad here's here's
the thing about this
actually my gripe is not with the
democrats asking for what i expect
democrats to ask for my gripe is with
the republicans they should absolutely
call the bluff the same way democrats
have called blood have refused to call
the bluff on the wall democrats
want something like this as a handout
but they want it for a specific group of
people people that went for you know
liberal studies like i did and didn't
pay for it with a leg and a leg like i
did and now have a lot of student loan
debt but can't get employed what
republicans should do is say okay you
want to give all those people student
loan debt forgiveness okay let's do a
tax credit to everybody who's already
paid theirs off for the next however
many years it takes thank you to get
that back let's also include trade
schools you know what let's not just
means test the people getting the
student loan forgiveness let's means
test the degree and if it comes out that
the most expensive degrees yield a much
lower income let's put legislation on
universities to not charge an absorbent
amount of money for a worthless degree
and by the way let's give the trade
schools the same opportunity okay
jessica find a word i like a lot of that
i think i like
all of it
um
this is the new new green deal issue
right so before the last election it was
like this has to get through now it's
turned into this and the most
interesting thing that i read about
why this is a problem or an education
problem not in terms of the degree that
you got is that people are graduating
with a four-year liberal arts degree
think that they will be paid 50 000
more per year than the actual market
dictates so they're going into this
thinking oh i'm going to come out i'm
going to 100 000 out of college no
you're not you're not unless you go into
finance or you go to a corporate law
firm you are not earning a hundred
thousand dollars right out of college
and you don't need to yep and we don't
want to pay for your revenue
ahead hillary called a hypocrite and the
liberal elites getting political at the
ritzy met gala
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now